[Applause]
talent
[Music]
here's five reasons you should watch
ballet
[Music]
right here
man every tape bro i'm telling you every
take this guy just gets better and
better and the professionalism once
again i can't speak to that enough
javari's a star you know and
i see why he was casted as well because
he has he has the chops he has the look
he has the attitude he takes direction
he takes notes he can adjust on the fly
he's a force as well as the rest of the
cast man you know working with you know
adrian cassandra coco all these guys
bring a lot to the table man and it's
great to see this fresh brand new energy
let's talk about simone joy jones for a
second she can sing she can act she can
dance she really does it all but above
all else she's amazing friend you know
what i mean and to have that on camera
and off camera and to see our
relationship grow is just so beautiful
and it means so much to me
[Music]
we're black black everything here black
excellence you know what i mean so fresh
prince and bel air they're they're both
a part of an incredible legacy black
excellence and
shows that can definitely go between the
comedy and the drama my family and i
would like to welcome you all to our
home just to be a part of that legacy
part of that story is so important to me
and to add another layer
onto the excellence that we get to see
on camera and on screen and display for
our community and our people is so huge
for me working with a crew full of
incredible people to bring this idea to
life i have so much gratitude for
everyone on this ball court so thank you
all for being here
[Music]
young jabari back here
you know doing his thing looking sharp
looking sharp as ever put no put the
camera in ah man
carlton's fashion sense he's trendy he's
a trendy and expensive dude i got
cufflinks
let's say cb
kim's got a carlton banks baby we rich
who has
a baby blue suit you know what i'm
saying like
carlton got sweat
[Applause]
let me show you what i got
air force ones
off white air forces these are concord
11s the classic jordan so my favorite
look is definitely this blue and white
girly two-piece set from balmain set
type of look but also like throwing it
back to like a clueless school girly
type super blinged out with like pearls
and diamonds and ice it was just
you think you know these people because
of the sitcom what if i told you the
sitcom was just dinner conversation and
this was like the diary of that story
whatever could not have been explored
in the old version of bel air or the
fresh prince of bel air
we're able to explore within this our
drama these are the characters you
remember you know and love we're
presenting them in a way that will
challenge some of your assumptions and
make it you think about them in new ways
why should people watch bel air
it's black excellence and it's beautiful
and it's good as [ __ ]
the cast is amazing their talent is
amazing these stories are compelling
i think people should watch bel air
because there's truly something for
everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you